it's michelle of lab muffin beauty
science here chemistry phd cosmetic
chemist and big fan of asian skin care
today i'm going to be talking about my
favorite hamish products hamish is a
korean brand that's best known for their
cleansing balm it has a cult following
and obviously i'll be talking about that
but they have a lot of other really
interesting products too this video is
sponsored by star korean an online
korean beauty store that stops hamish
along with tons of other brands like and
subscribe and click the notification
bell so you know when new videos go up
i'm going to start with the hamish all
clean balm this is hamish's most popular
product and lots of people have this as
their all-time favorite cleansing balm
and for good reason i've been using this
for years i don't think i've ever
reviewed it though and i should really
do a video on my favorite cleansing
balms but this one is very high up there
in case you didn't already know
cleansing balms are great for quickly
getting makeup and waterproof sunscreen
off your face really fast i talked about
this before in my cleansing mist video
but you don't actually need to use an
oil-based cleanser to remove makeup and
sunscreen a lot of the time regular
cleansers will work fine and you can
even remove them with microfiber cloths
and plain water but a lot of people
including me really like using oil based
cleansers for that because it feels
really effortless and the oil massage is
really relaxing so how you use these you
scoop out a small amount of the
cleansing balm then you massage it over
your dry dirty face at the start of your
cleansing routine the solid balm will
melt on your skin as you rub and it
turns into an oil then you rinse it off
with warm water i personally rub the
balm on before i get into the shower and
then i rinse it off in the shower and
you'll see the water go milky as it
emulsifies and the all droplets go into
the water you can follow up with a
regular cleanser like a foaming cleanser
which i do if i'm wearing makeup or if
you think your skin is clean enough you
can just leave it which is what i do if
i didn't leave the house and i didn't
wear sunscreen or makeup that day this
balm is a really good cleansing balm
that works really well to get rid of
waterproof makeup including mascara and
it rinses off really cleanly some
cleansing bars will leave a bit of oil
on your face and depending on the
product you can either leave this on
your face or you might prefer to get it
off with a follow-up cleanser i've
personally found that it really depends
on which balm i'm using whether or not i
break out with that extra oil but with
this one you don't have a layer left
behind so you don't need to worry about
it this is just one of the more
affordable cleansing balms that works
really well it's slightly centered it
has this flip top lid that makes it
really easy to get into it has a little
spot for storing your spatula if you're
a neat person who's not into digging out
the product with your fingers or just
like
smashing the spatula in there for
storage this product does have
polyethylene in it i'll talk more about
it in a future video because it's a bit
of a complicated topic but
very briefly this has a form of
polyethylene in it but there are lots of
different types of polyethylene and the
type in cleansing balms is probably
somewhat biodegradable it's a less solid
form than microbeads so the
environmental impacts are quite
different the amount in it is also
really small compared to the other
microplastics you generally produce in
the rest of your life so while i'd like
it if brands replaced it with more
degradable ingredients it isn't really a
big deal breaker for me i tried a bunch
of hamish's cleansers and these two are
my favorites this is the ph 5.5 all
clean green foam i really like that this
has a low skin friendly ph of 5.5
because a lot of asian cleansers tend to
have really high ph's high ph will
disrupt your skin a bit more than a
lower ph that matches your skin's ph
this foams nicely it cleanses nicely and
it doesn't leave my skin feeling tight
afterwards it is fragrance free and it
smells a bit plasticky as i've mentioned
before i do prefer a mild fragrance in
my cleanses to not have that smell this
is just very functional i think it's a
great option i personally find it a bit
boring but for a lot of people no frills
is exactly what you want in a cleanser
and if that's you i highly recommend
this there's also the all clean white
clay foam i actually like this a bit
more than the other one this is a
foaming cleanser that has two types of
clay in it which is bentonite and kaolin
so it soaks up oil as you clean it's
sort of like a way of getting the
benefits of a clay mask while you're
cleansing so
i love lazy products this does have a
high ph it's around eight or nine but
this is probably the nicest feeling high
ph cleanser i've ever tried it's soap
based but the soap's been mixed with
other non-soap surfactants which should
reduce the soap disrupting your skin
this also has glycerin in it which stops
your skin from getting too dehydrated
while cleansing i've talked about how
formulations can make surfactants work
gently in my cleanse and mist video as
well i didn't find this drying or tight
but i did try it during an australian
summer which is pretty humid and i have
oily skin i did try a couple of other
high ph soap based cleansers over the
last few months and they haven't worked
as well as this so i do think this is
actually gentler and i was actually
quite surprised it didn't feel tight
even though there is that clay in it
this also has hydrolyzed silk and
hyaluronic acid which would help keep
your skin hydrated as well
it has a light scent which comes from
essential oils and so i'd recommend this
for people with oily skin maybe go for
the other one if you have dry skin or
you're sensitive to fragrance moving on
to moisturizers hamish have a whole
bunch of really nice moisturizers and
these are my favorites one thing i love
about asian skincare is that there are a
lot of gel moisturizers available that
are really good for early dehydration
prone skin and just hot weather in
general standard moisturizers are
usually creams or lotions that are oil
in water emulsions and these use
traditional emulsifiers to keep all
droplets suspended in the product these
traditional emulsifiers can sometimes
feel pretty heavy with a gel cream the
oil droplets get suspended using a
network of special polymers and this
ends up feeling a lot lighter on your
skin gel creams are a lot more popular
in asia there aren't a ton of gel cream
options available at a lower price point
in australia so i was really excited to
try the watermelon moisture soothing gel
cream this is fantastic it used to be
called the moisture surge gel cream and
it's very similar to the clinique
version this has a very lightweight
texture but it's really hydrating
there's lots of glycerin in it and it
leaves behind a satiny hydrated looking
finish on my skin it doesn't peel i'm
actually wearing it now under my makeup
it's fragrance free and the smell is not
very offensive for a fragrance-free
product i also really like the all clean
vitamin blemish spot clear cream this is
a slightly heavier cream it's more
moisturizing but again it's really
hydrating with lots of glycerin it feels
really cooling when you put it on your
skin and i think i could still probably
use it as a heavier day cream this has a
light scent and it has five percent
niacinamide and vitamin c which comes
from kakadu plum extract it's actually
approved as a functional cosmetic in
korea for brightening and anti-wrinkle
claims and i believe that's because it
contains two to five percent niacinamide
and 0.04 adenosine but it does also have
clinical testing on the box which you
can see on this graph
and that shows that it has a modest
decrease in pigment and you can also see
some before and afters on the hamish
website the box also shows the
irritation testing and i think this is
just a really nice moisturizer i love
that you can get a high percentage of
niacinamide in one product which means
you can sort of spend your serums on
other ingredients moving on to the
marine care cream toner
this is a newer sort of product for me
it's a toner that has a lot of oil in it
but it's very watery as you can see but
it moisturizes a lot more like a lotion
this product is very similar to the
laneige cream skin which i also love
they both have very similar top line
moisturizing ingredients which are
butylene glycol and glycerin as
humectants as well as meta foam seed oil
as the oil component it's also approved
as a functional cosmetic for brightening
and anti-wrinkle in korea which i'm
guessing means that the niacinamide in
this is between two and five percent and
the adenosine is at 0.04
it also has marine extracts in it and
according to the packaging it's in
liposomal form which means they're
bundled up in little packets which
supposedly should deliver better into
your skin this also has a very mild
scent whereas the laneige is fragrance
free but on my skin the moisturizing
effect is pretty much the same for both
so i guess your choice would depend on
whether you want more actors and how you
feel about fragrance i also tried the
marine care eye cream i usually don't
use eye creams because i wear contact
lenses at night and if any product gets
into my eyes it is a massive pain i have
to go through the whole contact lens
removal and reinsertion process but i
gave this one a go because it has a
thicker texture and so i figured it
probably wouldn't travel as much and i
was right this does hydrate my under eye
area pretty nicely without traveling
into my eyes this also has that
niacinamide and adenosine combo that
makes it a functional cosmetic it also
has marine extracts and peptides again
it has that liposomal technology which
should deliver that deeper into your
skin this does have a moderate scent but
because you don't use very much product
it's not super noticeable it comes with
a metal de-puffing massage stick and
this is quite soothing i found myself
using it during the day when i was in
front of the computer and my eyes were
getting a bit tired i prefer applying
this cream by pressing it in with my
fingers because the texture is a bit
thick and so it's a bit difficult to
spread with the stick but massaging it
in with the cool stick afterwards is
really nice i don't think you
necessarily need a separate eye cream
unless you have the same problem as me
where your face likes products that
slide around but your eyes don't and i
guess i'm just not really an eye cream
connoisseur because i haven't tried that
many but i did find myself really
enjoying this i found myself reaching
for it a lot more than i expected my
final pick from the hamish range of the
products i tried is the black tea mask
pack
this has a really puree fluffy sorbet
sort of texture
it is moderately strongly scented and
it's quite a floral scent to use it you
apply it for five to ten minutes and
then you wash it off i wiped it off with
a damp cloth or cotton pad and i've
heard that some people leave this on
overnight i wasn't expecting a lot from
this product because you are only meant
to use it for five to ten minutes but i
was really impressed by how hydrating it
was in such a short amount of time the
effect this had was kind of like a sheet
mask without being a sheet mask i think
i've mentioned before how i don't really
like sheet masks because they're kind of
fussy to me i know a lot of people like
to relax with a sheet mask on but i find
that i don't really relax which
i know sounds kind of bad but i like to
do things while i relax like i like to
read or crochet and i don't like the
distraction of the feeling of the sheet
mask sliding down a layer of this feels
just like moisturizer and i found that
this gave me a lot of those hydrating
skin smoothing effects that shade masks
tend to give i haven't used a lot of
masks recently because they are just to
me a lot of effort but this is like a
really low effort mask that still
delivers a lot of benefits so those are
my favorite hamish products so far all
the links to buy are in the description
and they're currently on sale at style
korean let me know if you've tried any
of these products before and what you
thought of them i've also got some more
reviews of asian skincare products in
the description you can follow me on
instagram tiktok check out my blog and
see you next time for more nerdy beauty
talk